1. Juni 2019. Kurz vor Mitternacht. Walter
Lübcke raucht noch eine Zigarette.
Er ahnt nicht, dass ein Neonazi ihn im Visier
hat.
Dann ein Schuss. Aus nächster Nähe trifft
eine Kugel Walter Lübckes Kopf.
“Ich war fassungslos und bin in Tränen
ausgebrochen.”
Der mutmaßlicher Mörder: der hessische Neonazi
Stephan Ernst. So sieht es die Bundesanwaltschaft.
Für die Ermittler ein Mord, über Monate
geplant.
Der Fall gilt als erster rechtsextremer Mord
an einem Politiker in der Geschichte der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland.
Wie konnte es zum Mord an Walter Lübcke kommen?
Familienvater, CDU-Politiker und Kasseler
Regierungspräsident.
Wir werten hunderte Seiten Ermittlungsakten
aus, Zeugenbefragungen und interne Dokumente.
Wir sind auf der Spur des mutmaßlichen Täters
- und seines Opfers:
Wenn man die Geschichte von Stephan Ernst
und seinem Opfer Walter Lübcke recherchiert,
stößt man unweigerlich auf dieses Video:
„Es lohnt sich, in unserem Land zu leben.
Da muss man für Werte eintreten, und wer
diese Werte nicht vertritt, der kann jederzeit
dieses Land verlassen. Das ist die Freiheit
eines jeden Deutschen“
Im Jahr 2019 kursiert das über drei Jahre
alte Video wieder in den sozialen Netzwerken.
Erika Steinbach - mittlerweile im AfD-Umfeld
aktiv - verweist auf das Video.
Was folgt ist neuer Hass: Gegen Walter Lübcke.
„Es war für mich völlig unvermittelt,
dass plötzlich dieses Video wieder auftauchte.
Und das hat ja auch unter anderem Erika Steinbach
auf ihrem Facebook oder Twitter-Account nochmal
verbreitet. Dadurch hat es nochmal eine besondere
Dynamik gekriegt. Und erst später gab es
dann neue Drohungen, Mails
Auch Stephan Ernst teilt das Video. Er schreibt
eine SMS an seine Mutter:
„Hallo Mama , schau dir das an...Da siehst
du wie weit sich dieser Abschaum von Volksverrätern
von uns entfernt hat“
Ein Rückblick - Was genau geschah an dem
Abend, an dem das Video entstand?
14. Oktober 2015.
Regierungspräsident Walter Lübcke lädt
zur Bürgerversammlung.
In Lohfelden soll in einem leerstehenden Gartencenter
eine Flüchtlingsunterkunft entstehen. Lübcke
will informieren, aufklären und Ängste nehmen.
Zur Versammlung kommen über 800 Gäste - darunter
auch Rechtsextremisten, die das Heim verhindern
wollen.
Ich habe das genau so wahrgenommen, dass es
einige Leute im Saal gab, die bewusst stören
wollten, die Dr. Lübcke vor allem aus der
ersten Reihe ständig unterbrochen haben mit
“Volksverräter”, “Scheiß-Staat”,
“Hau ab” und so weiter.“
Die Stimmung im Saal ist aufgeheizt.
Unter den Anwesenden: Lübckes späterer mutmaßlicher
Mörder Stephan Ernst. Er hat einen Begleiter
bei sich: Markus H. Er ist es, der das Video
noch am Abend bei Youtube hochlädt.
Dort bricht daraufhin eine Hasswelle gegen
Lübcke los:
“Der Kasper aus Kassel macht’s nicht mehr
lange.“
„Möge der Kerl bekommen, was er verdient.“
Reaktionen, die auch Walter Lübcke beunruhigen.
Hat wohl seine Frau angerufen und gesagt,
sie soll mit ihren beiden Söhnen zu Verwandten
oder Bekannten gehen, das Haus erst einmal
verlassen.“
Ein Schlüsselmoment für Ernst. In den Akten
heißt es später: Bei der Bürgerversammlung
sei Ernst klar geworden, dass Lübcke „ein
Volksschädling sei, der beseitigt werden
müsse“.
Wir wollen mehr erfahren: wer ist Stephan
Ernst? Woher kommt sein Hass gegen Fremde?
Und vor allem: warum konnte der Mord an Walter
Lübcke nicht verhindert werden?
Wir fahren nach Hohenstein. Drei Autostunden
von Lohfelden entfernt. Hier ist Stephan Ernst
aufgewachsen.
Die Radikalisierung des mutmaßlichen Mörders
beginnt früh.
Mit 15 Jahren zündet er ein Wohnhaus an.
Sein Motiv: Hass auf die dort lebenden Türken.
Er habe denen „einen Denkzettel geben“
wollen.
3 Jahre später dann schon eine ganz andere
Art von Gewalt. Ein Anschlag auf bosnische
Flüchtlinge – in einem Nachbarort. Mit
einer selbstgebauten Bombe.
Der Sprengsatz explodiert nicht, die Heimbewohner
können das Feuer löschen.
Wir treffen Adolf Bremer. Er war damals als
Polizist am Tatort und vernahm Stephan Ernst.
Dem pensionierten Ermittler fällt das Sprechen
schwer.
„Dann fing der an zu schimpfen, alles scheiße,
das Leben macht überhaupt keinen Spaß mehr,
soll am besten hinterein springen??? Und da
hat er gesagt dass er das gemacht hat.“
Ernst fasst Vertrauen zu Polizist Bremer und
gesteht ihm später noch einen weiteren Mordversuch.
Diesen verübt er auf einer Bahnhofstoilette
in Wiesbaden. Hier trifft er zufällig auf
einen Mann. Der sieht aus wie ein Ausländer.
Ernst sticht zu, in den Rücken, in die Brust.
Das Opfer: ein türkischer Imam, kämpft wochenlang
um sein Leben.
Für das Landgericht Wiesbaden ist der Messerangriff
versuchter Totschlag. Der Rohrbombenanschlag
- kein Mordversuch - sondern versuchte Herbeiführung
einer Sprengstoffexplosion.
Das Gericht verurteilt Stephan Ernst zu zu
6 Jahren Haft, wertet seinen Charakter als
strafmildernd.
Er sei „in seiner Steuerungsfähigkeit erheblich..beeinträchtigt“
gewesen, habe eine „Borderline-Persönlichkeitsstörung
und eine „schwere andere seelische Abartigkeit“.
„Dass in der Gerichtsentscheidung zu dem
Mordanschlag auf dem Imam im Wiesbadener Hauptbahnhof
Stefan Ernst attestiert wird, dass er seelisch
abartig sei in früher Jugend, das zeigt ja
offensichtlich sozusagen, dass er wie eine
tickende Zeitbombe schon damals eingeschätzt
wurde. Was sich leider bestätigt hat. „
Hätten die Sicherheitsbehörden den mutmaßlichen
Täter schon früher stoppen können? Mit
dieser Frage wird sich der Untersuchungsausschuss
im hessischen Landtag zum Mordfall Lübcke
beschäftigen.
Zur gleichen Zeit, als Stephan Ernst einen
Imam in der Bahnhofstoilette niedersticht,
engagiert sich Walter Lübcke 1992 in Thüringen
als Politiker in der Jugendarbeit.
Lübcke veranstaltet Konzerte, „Rock gegen
Gewalt“. Die Konzertwochenenden richten
sich auch gegen die örtliche Neonaziszene.
Lübcke sei immer ein Kämpfer für die Grundrechte
gewesen, sagen Wegbegleiter.
04.16.2016 „Die Verfassung, die Grundrechte,
die Freiheit in Deutschland das war für ihn
etwas ganz, ganz Wesentliches. Das hat ihn
geprägt, das hat seine Haltung immer bestimmt,
und dazu gehört auch Meinungsfreiheit, also
auch eine andere Meinung zu haben als die
Mainstreammeinung.“
1999 kehrt Lübcke von Thüringen zurück
nach Hessen. Er wird in den hessischen Landtag
gewählt.
Im selben Jahr kommt Stephan Ernst nach sechs
Jahren Haft frei. Er findet sofort Anschluss
an die Kasseler Neonazi-Szene.
Das berichten Antifaschisten, die sich seit
Jahren mit den rechtsextremen Strukturen in
Hessen beschäftigen. Sie wollen nicht erkannt
werden.
„Stefan Ernst ist in einem Umfeld verkehrt,
wo sich ein breites Spektrum wiedergefunden
hat, es gab Personen aus der Kameradschaft
Szene, es gab Personen aus der Hooligan-Szene,
NPD Führungskader.... „
„Mit dabei sind Personen aus dem Combat
18-Spektrum, aus dem Rocker-Milieu KSV Hooligans.
Eine ganze Bandbreite.
In dieser Szene lernt Stephan Ernst seinen
späteren Mittäter Markus H. kennen, der
auch das Youtube Video von Lübcke hochlud.
Die Bundesanwaltschaft wirft Markus H. vor,
Ernst bei seinem Mordplan unterstützt zu
haben und hat ihn wegen Beihilfe zum Mord
angeklagt. Markus H. habe gesagt, dass Walther
Lübcke „erhängt“ werden müsse.
Laut Ermittlungsakten verherrlicht Markus
H. den Nationalsozialismus und ist ein Waffennarr.
Stephan Ernst und Markus H. fallen den Behörden
wiederholt auf. So auch 2009.
Am 1. Mai werden beide zusammen mit vierhundert
anderen Rechtsradikalen wegen Gewalttaten
auf einer DGB-Kundgebung in Dortmund festgenommen.
Der hessische Verfassungsschutz hält sie
für gefährlich.
00.12.2013 „Wir haben dort ein Dokument
vorgefunden über mehrere besonders militante
Neonazis aus Nordhessen. Und da war Stefan
Ernst mit aufgeführt, im übrigen auch sein
Kumpel Markus H. Und bei Stefan Ernst gab
es eine handschriftliche Randbemerkung. Er
sei brandgefährlich.“
Der hessische Verfassungsschutz beobachtet
Ernst bis 2009 auf zahlreichen rechtsextremistischen
Versammlungen.
Den Ermittlern Im Mordfall Lübcke erzählt
der mutmaßliche Mörder Ernst, er habe sich
spätestens 2011 aus der Szene gelöst.
2011 wird die Mordserie des nationalsozialistischen
Untergrundes bekannt. Auch in Kassel hatten
Uwe Mundlos und Uwe Böhnhardt gemordet: Den
Internetcafé-Betreiber Halit Yozgat richteten
sie per Kopfschuss hin.
Zur Aufklärung der NSU Morde wären damals
Erkenntnisse über die Kasseler Naziszene
hilfreich gewesen. Doch der hessische Verfassungsschutz
kann wenig beitragen. Denn Akten zur regionalen
Neonaziszene wurden gelöscht oder sind gesperrt.
„Da steht zum Beispiel: Wir finden über
550 Stücke mit Neonazi-Bezügen im Landesamt
für Verfassungsschutz. Also auf jeden Fall
kann und konnte diese Behörde ihre Aufgabe,
nämlich uns vor rechtsextremen Terroristen
zu schützen, nicht erfüllen.“
Dezember 2015: Im hessischen NSU-Untersuchungsausschuss
wird eine Verfassungsschutzbeamtin zu Stephan
Ernst befragt. Sie sagt: dessen Akte sei gelöscht
oder gesperrt. So kann sie nicht erklären,
warum der Geheimdienst Stephan Ernst nach
2009 einen „abgekühlten“ Neonazi nennt
und deshalb nicht mehr beobachtet.
„Was uns allerdings nicht bekannt war zum
damaligen Zeitpunkt war, dass es so eine Personalakte
im Verfassungsschutz über Stephan Ernst gab,
die just zu diesem Zeitpunkt, als wir nachgefragt
haben, im Jahre 2015 dann auch intern gelöscht
wurde, also nicht mehr zugänglich war für
keinen Mitarbeiter im Verfassungsschutz selber,
bundesweit.“
Der Verfassungsschutz ordnete an, die Berichte
über Rechtsextreme „als Verschlusssachen...einzustufen.“
So wurde die Geheimhaltungs- „Frist auf
30 Jahre festgelegt.“
Warum hält der Verfassungsschutz die Akten
zu Stephan Ernst und Markus H. jahrzehntelang
geheim? Waren die Kasseler Neonazis V-Leute?
Das haben die Behörden klar dementiert. Nach
Frontal-Recherchen trafen sich 1998 Mitarbeiter
des Verfassungsschutzes drei Stunden lang
mit Markus H. in Kassel. Sie wollen H. als
Spitzel anwerben. Doch der sagte nein.
Wir besuchen einen Schießplatz nördlich
von Kassel. Hier trainierte Markus H. mit
Waffen und brachte Stephan Ernst das Schießen
bei.
Reporter: Haben Sie den Ernst mal hier gesehen?
O-Ton: Ich kannte den ja nicht, der wurde
von Markus H. mitgebracht.
Die Anklage wirft Markus H. vor: Durch die
Schießübungen habe er Ernst in seinen Mordplänen
bestärkt.
Doch warum durften zwei Rechtsradikale überhaupt
mit Waffen hantieren?
Die Antwort überrascht: Markus H. erstritt
sich 2015 vor Gericht eine Waffenbesitzkarte
- obwohl Ordnungsamt und Verfassungsschutz
Bedenken hatten.
Die ehemalige Lebensgefährtin von Markus
H. beschreibt ihn laut Akten als gefühlslosen
Neonazi und sagt: „Sein Motto war, wir Deutschen
brauchen Waffen“.
Laut Anklage hantierte er sogar mit Sprengstoff.
Er habe diesen selber hergestellt und Probesprengungen
durchgeführt.
Über einen Kontakt von Markus H. soll Stephan
Ernst dann später auch an die Mordwaffe gekommen
sein.
Wir finden den mutmaßlichen Waffenhändler
19.17 O-Ton Reporter: „Ich will bloß verstehen,
wie ist der Ernst, wie sind Sie zusammengekommen?“
O-Ton Elmar J., Trödel- und Waffenhändler
„Ich hab ihm zwei Bajonette mal verkauft
in den letzten zehn Jahren. Ja, ich habe den
kennengelernt, total relaxed, niemals Schaum
vorm Mund. Ganz ruhig Das glaubt mir heute
keiner. Aber das ist so.
Elmar J. bestreitet, die Tatwaffe besorgt
zu haben. Doch gegen ihn läuft deshalb ein
separates Strafverfahren.
Zurück nach Lohfelden. Nach der Einwohnerversammlung,
auf der das folgenschwere Video entstand,
wurden 800 Asylsuchende in einem ehemaligen
Gartencenter untergebracht. Ganz in der Nähe
der Wohnung von Stephan Ernst.
6. Januar 2016. Am Abend verlässt der Iraker
Ahmad E. das Heim, um Zigaretten zu holen.
Ein Mann nähert sich mit dem Fahrrad und
sticht ihn mit einem Messer nieder.
Der Täter ist nach Ansicht der Bundesanwaltschaft
Stephan Ernst.
Ahmad E. überlebt, sagt später gegenüber
der Polizei aus:
„Er hat mich gestochen und hat dann mit
dem Fuß nach mir getreten, so dass ich nicht
vor ihn falle, sondern zur Seite. Ich habe
mehrfach versucht hoch zu kommen, habe es
jedoch nicht geschafft. Ich fühlte mich wie
gelähmt.“
Ahmad E. weist die Ermittler mehrfach auf
einen möglichen rechtsextremen Täter hin.
Doch ohne Folgen.
[00:04:43] „Nach meinem bisherigen Stand
hat man keine Ermittlungen in Richtung rassistischer
Tathintergrund beziehungsweise Naziszene gemacht,
jedenfalls aus dem Teil de Akten, den ich
bisher gesehen habe, ergibt sich das nicht,
obwohl mein Mandant sehr, sehr vorsichtig,
aber doch klar mehrfach auf diese Möglichkeit
hingewiesen hat
Mai 2018. Bewaffnet mit seinem Revolver späht
Stephan Ernst erneut Lübckes Wohnhaus aus.
Immer wieder lauert er dem Regierungspräsidenten
auf, um ihn zu töten. Er bereitet sich gewissenhaft
auf den Anschlag vor, arbeitet „Vorsichtsregeln“
aus:
„Lange Kontrolle und Beobachtung des Tatorts
vor der Tatausführung.“
„An Tatwaffen dürfen keine Haare oder Textilfasern
haften, weder von dir noch vom Opfer.“
„Was brauche ich an Material, Tatwerkzeug
und Waffen: eventuell Pistole oder Schrottflinte
und Nachtsichtgerät....“
Er hat sich darauf vorbereitet.Das war keine
spontane Tat. Es war geplant, eine über viele,
viele Monate hinweg konkret geplante Mord-Aktion.“
Erster September 2018. Neun Monate vor dem
Mordanschlag.
Der sogenannte Trauermarsch der AfD in Chemnitz.
In der Stadt war zuvor ein Mann niedergestochen
worden – von einem Asylbewerber.
In Chemnitz marschieren Stephan Ernst und
Markus H. gemeinsam mit anderen Rechtsradikalen
- und der AfD.
„Ich denke schon, dass bei der Radikalisierung
von Stefan Ernst die Thüringer AfD und insbesondere
Björn Höcke eine ganz entscheidende Rolle
spielen. Er hat sich ja immer dort hingezogen
gefühlt. Nicht nur durch die Spenden, sondern
auch durch die Teilnahme an Demonstrationen
(in Erfurt zum Beispiel im Jahr 2018 und vieles
mehr.“)
1. Juni 2019, kurz vor Mitternacht. Jahrelang
hat Stephan Ernst Mordpläne gegen Lübcke
geschmiedet, und niemand hat ihn daran gehindert,
sich zu bewaffnen. Mindestens drei Mal zuvor
war Stephan Ernst schon am Wohnhaus von Walter
Lübcke. Jetzt ist es so weit.
Stephan Ernst schießt Walter Lübcke ohne
Vorwarnung aus einem Revolver in den Kopf,
so die Anklage der Bundesanwaltschaft. Der
Regierungspräsident erliegt seiner schweren
Kopfverletzung.
„Und dann kam sofort hoch die Bürgerversammlung
Lohfelden und dann hab ich noch auf Facebook
sinngemäß gepostet. Vor vier Jahren hat
er Polizeischutz gehabt, da ist nichts passiert
und jetzt das. Ich habe intuitiv eine Verbindung
hergestellt.“
Bis heute kursiert das Video der mutmaßlichen
Täter im Netz, Hasskommentare inklusive.
„Ich werde nicht aufhören dafür zu kämpfen,
dass solche Dinge eben auch rausgenommen werden.
Und dass die Opfer von Video, die ja auch
immer noch … leben und davon betroffen sind,
immer noch geschädigt werden, dadurch, dass
die Videos im Netz kursieren. Es geht um Opferschutz.“
Der mutmaßliche Mörder muss sich vor Gericht
verantworten. Stephan Ernst bestreitet die
Tat, hat sein Geständnis widerrufen, schiebt
die Schuld auf seinen Kumpanen Markus H. Der
Schuss sei nur ausversehen losgegangen. Die
Bundesanwaltschaft glaubt das nicht
In Kassel trauern sie um einen Politiker mit
Rückgrat, der die offene Gesellschaft verteidigte.
Call to Action:
Rechter Terror – unterschätzen die deutschen
Sicherheitsbehörden die Gefahr? Schreibt
es uns in die Kommentare.